so how are things all right I'm gonna
take a look at what I would consider to
be a Doctor Who oddity
these are little bits of Doctor Who
generally non-canon and just kind of
weird little things that kind of yeah
that happened some examples of this
would actually include the Doctor Who
movies starring Peter Cushing the
animated short scream of the schalke I'd
actually throw in the animated things
like dreamland and the infinite quest
but today we're gonna talk about the
curse of the fatal death so this was a
children and in need special now if you
watch Doctor Who you may be familiar
with the children in need special doctor
who has done quite a few since coming
back the thing is though this was done
while doctor who was off the air I
should have checked the exact year but
this was done in the 90s so doctor who
went off the air originally in 89
it had the TV movie in 96 I do believe
this was actually done after that
because they refer to the doctor that we
start out with as the ninth doctor which
means the eighth already happened okay
so it's 96 or later and then the show
didn't come back properly until 2005 so
what this is is a spoof it is having fun
at what was at that point all of Doctor
Who what we would now consider to be
classic Doctor Who poking a bit of fun
gentle nudging loving mockery written by
Steven Moffat yeah that's even Moffat
which makes it all the stranger as a as
a thing unto itself this was an odd
thing Wow I mean it's an odd thing in
the first place
but this was an odd thing for me too
go and watch again and I say again cuz
I've watched it before largely because
I'd heard so many great things about it
and I remember watching for the first
time I'm going why do people like this
so much and watching it a second time I
kind of still feel that there's now I am
going to grant that there is probably a
fair amount of this humour that would
have landed better at the time aired
with Doctor Who not having come back yet
none of the ships and I guess I mean
remember while I am continuing to work
on filling in my gaps on classic who I
came in to Doctor Who during the modern
era
my initial hooking was Tennant and then
I started with Eccleston so the entire
perspective with which I'm coming at
this thing is strictly speaking the
wrong perspective because it was written
for an audience that new classic who and
at the time it aired that's all there
was that in like novelizations and the
occasional comic and whatnot so the
natural perspective that I have is not
the one that was intended for the
audience to have but I also can't help
that so nowadays the Doctor Who children
are need specials run five ish five six
minutes ballpark this is 22 it's
actually broken into two parts it has a
part one and a part two and a recap made
it way through so this is actually
fairly lengthy and it's kinda is kind of
impressive cast as it goes along as well
I am gonna be breaking this thing down
as it goes so if you haven't seen it yet
pause this look up curse the fatal death
is for free available on YouTube like
officially on the Doctor Who channel and
on children and needs channel so watch
it and come on back because otherwise
I'm just gonna start talking jokes and
you know there you go and that's kind of
the big thing most of the jokes don't
land
for me I think some of it's just because
it's some of the humor is really
juvenile some of the humor really
amounts to farts poop breasts and I'd
like you got to do better than that I'm
not saying that there are not or can't
be good jokes about farts or poop or
breasts but when the punch line is just
fart poop breasts which it is in the
cases where that is the core of the joke
they're not making a joke about those
things that's the punchline no I'm not
I'm not gonna laugh at that I've been
called a comedy snob more than a few
times by friends of mine so if you want
to call me that too you won't be the
first you'll be in very good company so
it kind of gets me off on the wrong foot
right off the bat that said the actually
the performance of the the the most
gusto performance in this is not of the
doctor it is of the master played here
by Jonathan Pryce and Jonathan Pryce
very clearly doing the Anthony Ainley
master I mean yo he's got the goatee
which actually was the only way the
master of being depicted when he wasn't
burnt to a crisp up to that point but
you know he is really just hamming it up
and he's really sinking his teeth into
this and that helps it doesn't I mean
well the jokes don't land the jokes
don't land but the man's committed and
that certainly works
the initial doctor we get is Rowan
Atkinson which is not as funny as you
think it is like once the initial kind
of hey dr. Beane's the doctor wears off
yeah I mean he plays it very straight
honestly there isn't a lot of inherent
humor in his portion of of the thing I
mean some of the
silly okay I've sort of been complaining
a little bit here's some of the stuff
that does work I like for lack of a
better term the timey wimey jokes they
go on a little too much actually I think
each of them go on for at least one beat
too long but the idea of like the doctor
and the master trying to one-up each
other because they go to meet at this
castle and the setup is they each went
back in time to bribe the architect like
set up a trap or something but that I
was like oh I knew you'd do that so I
went even earlier and I bribed the
architect before you and you know I kind
of liked that I like the use of time
travel for that similarly when the
master gets knocked into the sewers
unfortunately some of that does feed
into the poop humour but I like the idea
he falls in the sewers and he pops and
we see him show up again like a few
seconds later and he is significantly
older because it takes him hundreds of
years to crawl through the sewers and
get out again
and then he keeps getting knocked down
into the thing and coming out older and
older and older that's a decent joke so
there are some for me most of the best
jokes are a bit more on the subtle side
like at the very opening we start with
the master in his TARDIS and we also see
the doctor in his what makes me laugh
about that is the central part of the
console you know the bit that goes up
and down it's going like this it's so
unhinged and like there were times in
classic who where like the thing didn't
go perfectly straight up and down but
like this is ridiculous how much and
nobody draws attention to it it just is
like that's a good joke the the doctor
and his companion they run down the
exact same chunk of corridor three times
I liked that until she felt the need to
point it out I actually liked it better
before they said anything I actually
thought hey they didn't even have to say
it it's that oh they just said it but up
until they said it like I did enjoy that
joke
the Daleks showing up are actual legit
Daleks that works quite well so you know
that lends a bit of authenticity and
honestly the production values are no
worse than latter-day classic ever
Doctor Who anyway so that works pretty
well the best
joke by far because it's do it I think
it's one of the better jokes in general
and it's delivered the best is in the
second half of the thing and it's a
recurring joke of I'll explain later
so the kebaya has why did why do the
Daleks never just exterminate you why do
they always capture you I'll explain
later
that'll help the Daleks take over the
universe how will it do that I'll
explain later
I'd like I love that because that's the
kind of hand wavy thing that doctor who
has a tendency to doon then and now and
I like that it's just done they don't
highlight it
they don't go like hey are you ever
gonna actually explain it you just gonna
brush me off by saying I'll explain
later
no they just do it let the joke stand on
its own it's a good joke so that's one
of the better ones and and like I said
that one does recur and then we start
getting into the regeneration gags which
is that things keep happening that
caused the doctor to regenerate so
initially we go from Rowan Atkinson to
Richard II grant now Richard II grant he
is enjoyable largely because of how
sharp of contrast he was Rowan Atkinson
as I said actually playing the part
pretty straight about the only thing
that was off was how flat-out romantic
and like saying he's gonna marry his
campaign which I'm gonna guess was
probably a dig at the movie with Paul
McGann which would have had the first
onscreen kiss between the doctor and
companion and fans hated that so that's
probably what that was a dig at but
having Richard e-grant show up and you
know be you know kind of slick and kind
of cool but also a little sleazy a
little into like he sees the mirror and
licks his reflection like okay I like
too much of him wouldn't have worked but
like the sharp contrast from what it was
when it was a consent to that that works
pretty well and then he goes back to
rewire or something and there's a small
explosion he comes out and now it's Jim
Broadbent and again the
sharpness of the contrast is quite
lovely in addition to the fact that it's
just so exaggerated how they oh gee
you're my fiancee huh rather shy around
girls now like again dragged out much
longer than it was wouldn't it worked
but because the regeneration jokes are
basically coming one right after the
other and not lingering too long the way
that some of the earlier jokes did like
I hate to go on about the fart jokes
like and like the Virgil does actually
eventually pay off like it wasn't it
they did build off it for later on but I
still feel like both times it came up
with the initial setup in the beginning
and then later paying off with the
master and the doctor communicating to
him through the smell of his farts I
still think that joke goes on too long
the regeneration jokes don't really
outstay their welcome
so after broadband we get Hugh Grant
which I took that joke to be nobody this
big whatever play this part cuz in the
late 90s you Grant was huge because as
far as characterization goes he's not
that far off from the other ones that we
saw up to that point a little more what
was considered dashingly handsome at the
time but that's kind of it then we get
to the final surprise regeneration of
the doctor as a woman which probably
played pretty well as a joke at the time
in hindsight not so much and I don't
just mean that because the doctor is now
a woman I mean because if you actually
examine that joke and what's and why
it's supposed to be funny that's only a
joke if the very core notion of the
doctor ever being a woman is inherently
funny ie
inherently wrong and I'm not like
shaking my finger at Moffat for that
certainly at the time it was made that
was kind of the general consensus
opinion and I'm not even necessarily
going to hold that
if it continued to have that opinion
since then but what I am gonna say is
it's something knowing the basis of that
joke and seeing what Doctor Who fandom
has been like in the last few years I'm
I for one I'm not really comfortable
laughing at that now if I ever was
beyond the fact that she actually and
like this kind of makes the problem
worse joanna lumley as the doctor only
really has one or two like proper jokes
in the beginning and ones about her
breasts and the others about a vibrator
and after that she actually doesn't have
any jokes she's just the female doctor
isn't that funny
and and so I aside from the
uncomfortableness like I just don't
think it's very funny like they after
the after the sonic screwdriver as
vibrator joke
they stopped bothering giving her jokes
she's just standing there being a woman
doctor and apparently that's supposed to
be enough to be funny
it's not but you know she's game for it
she gives it a go as all the performers
do even though like I said Jonathan
Pryce completely choose the scenery in
the best way
oh that was that was another really good
line with Richard II grant I when he
turns sees the message you're the camp
one and I am NOT camp it's that's pretty
amusing I said there's little bits and
pieces that are funny but like part of
me wants to go at this thing with a
hacksaw trim it down to about five to
six minutes and either like trim out
some of the jokes that went on too long
trim out the jokes that flat-out don't
work and make this a really tight little
thing around the jokes that actually do
work because they are here and like I
said I think you get maximum eight
minutes out of that but because they
went for the full 22 not all the jokes
work
not for me some of them go on too long
you know I had hoped I'd find more out
of it this time because again like I
said I remember seeing for the first
time years ago and thinking no that's
like that feels like very scraping the
barrel very obvious jokes to be making
for the most part because I think that's
why I prefer like the joke about the
doctor the master why not being each
other going back in time over and over
again or the joke about I'll explain
later
because those are jokes you really can
make only make about Doctor Who they are
based off an understanding of the
property haha farts ha ha poop ha ha
boobs you could make those jokes about
anything I mean those jokes structurally
could be applied to any parody of
anything
there's nothing uniquely Doctor Who
about them they're just generic cheap
punch lines slapped onto a Doctor Who
spoof so this thing is that it's best
when it is properly lampooning the
unique qualities of Doctor Who it's just
not always doing that so that's my
thought on the curse of the fatal death
I have a feeling that this review is not
going to be well received because I
can't think of anybody talking about
that thing where I haven't gotten the
impression that they were talking about
that with great affection this will be
lots of fun whatever your thoughts are
just something down in the comments
let's talk about it I'm if you wish to
support me I've got a patreon helps pay
my bills additionally there's other
stuff below there's you know my p.o box
and socials and so forth so go on ahead
and check them out leave a comment as I
said but also you know you don't have to
do any of that I greatly appreciate it
but at the end of the day folks you're
the council I'm just running the
meetings please don't hurt me and until
next time this council is adjourned
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]